I think this is a perfect show for you
and I'm so glad that you're doing more
of them thank you yeah we're doing what
they picked us up we're doing another
season
[Music]
it's a lovely show you know I've long
been a huge fan of yours and I could
watch you read from a phonebook as they
say and whatever you're doing something
the I goes to to you it really does
I'm fascinated watch I know you have
this show where if something interests
you you go and you just ask all these
questions and you find out about things
that fascinate you it's a great idea for
show was this something that you pitch
did they come to you did someone else
have this I know you know what happened
I was they had that show on the NatGeo
channel explorer and they were tinkering
around with the format and they had me
subbed the hosts a few an arc of three
right and I did it had a great time
loved them and then we started they got
the idea that we're starting to talk
about it and you know what now you've
been investigating all kinds of things
what if you wanted to investigate that
you haven't investigated yet or
something that you just really want to
get into I think we've already chose
we've talked about it the first four
episodes are gonna be I hope I can
mention them are dogs I love dogs I'd
love to know more about dogs and also
fireworks we may do mouths oh by the way
yeah yeah yeah it's nothing to be part
of the same episode monsters and and
magic may magic yes now are you a guy
that took the student magic I like magic
yeah I've always liked magic a little
bit I was I was interested in Houdini
early on I read an article when I was a
kid and do you do magic I don't know
do you know Johnny Carson didn't mention
Johnny Carson the great talks were
legend of all time was very good at
magical level that's right we did
close-up work he's very good in light of
hands that's right he produced The Big
Chill in 1983 we went to his Malibu
house the cast for an icebreaker did I
ever tell you about no you went the 20
corsets how he did and he was there for
an afternoon and and had a colorful
sweater on
speaking of which and and did he
entertained us with some magic for a
while that's right did you learn any
magic I learned magic and I brought I
knew we were might talk about this so I
brought something that I could possibly
show you Robert Altman the great Robert
Altman anybody know Robert Altman dr. T
in the women of course you did with
Laura Dern and Richard Gere yeah Laura
Dern I'm gonna be reunited with in
Jurassic world
oh we're gonna shine Sam Neill all come
together in any case I did this movie
Nashville 1973 and I learned a bunch of
tricks that he said bring and I learned
some rope tricks and the only thing that
I've kept up with is my rope tricks oh
I'd love to see a rope I could do a
little series of rope tricks here we go
here's now watch closely watch closely
here is a knot right there yeah that has
discipline to that knot here also is a
that's certainly an oh my gosh that's
certainly or not but what happened to
that not all oh did you hear the audible
gasp this is like children at a party
and I watch closely if you're a magician
like I myself you can make an actual not
with yes with one hand
[Applause]
thank you and then fire and then finally
when I was a kid I used to of course
just like you get my shoes all oh boy
that was a they used to be disastrous
like that right now but watch this blow
on this maybe you're magical too
[Applause]
that is that is a talk-show guess
someone who comes out does some scatting
some musical bits some funny stories and
then ends with rope tricks that is
impressive Johnny Carson story Johnny
Carson stories that was amazing I want
to mention something at the very unfold
before we do I want to ship make sure we
show a clip this is a clip of the world
according to Jeff Goldblum and I think
this is a fascinating segment where
people who've lost their pets and who
cremate the pet but want to still say
stay close to the pet have an
interesting way of doing it should we
show the clip please let's take a look
news I had already set up to have her
cremated because I wanted to keep her
with me forever
what did you imagine you do yes yes I
could not believe this was possible yeah
but I was able to turn her ashes a small
portion of her ashes into a diamond
Jacob discovered the world of synthetic
diamonds where high-pressure heat
technology mimics the geological process
of diamond creation so you found out
about it and then you said I want to
work there I said I want to work there
but you didn't work for him at the time
not at the time wait a minute so you're
holding in your hands now this is her
diamond you ever need you don't have
song government uh forever diamonds are
forever right it's absolutely true so
open it up and that is Miss Piggy so
that's his dog his dog head his dog
turned into a diamond
yes Wow that is uh that's that's intense
its intense yeah he was very much you
know he was very seriously attached to
that dog as we you know many of us are
yeah we have a dog you know yeah yeah
but would you make a diamond out of yeah
I would make a diamond out of mine yeah
I wouldn't I love my dog but I mean yeah
Diamond dove it have my memories yeah
exactly that's the real jewel is the
memory of the dog that's the true
treasure not the diamond itself is Kavya
Baba
[Laughter]
I want to mention something you're doing
before we have to go to the to the
hospital both of us you were going to
Sacramento for I think a very good cause
you're gonna help with a bill that's
limiting plastic one use plastic is that
right yeah yeah tomorrow morning I'm
gonna fly there talk to lawmakers and
this and that there's a bill that we
hope is gonna get passed which will
limit the production of plastic
especially single-use plastic because
the amount of plastic that's going into
the ocean seventeen billion or is a huge
amounts going into the oceans and all of
us yeah we got a fix it fix it up we got
to clean things up and I think we're
going to before you go home we're gonna
give everybody a metal straw so they
don't have to you ever use a plan
nice
fantastic Oh settle down it's a metal
Jesus yeah like rose Allen you'd be
getting a flat-screen TV
I saw those medals I thought we were all
doing cocaine after the show the row
that poor did Jeff Goldblum is streaming
now on Disney Plus check it out - great
show and Jeff Goldblum and the Mildred
Schnitzer orchestras second album I
shouldn't be telling you this is out now
I love this man Jeff Goldblum he look
[Applause]